this is how those that knew sabine
anessa want to remember her a smiling
and happy primary school teacher
her murder has left her family seen
arriving here at the old bailey
devastated and angry
another shocking case of violence
against women
my sister was um funny
lovable caring
it's been horrendous
it's broken us
deeply um we have never thought that
we'll be in this situation
like um
you would hear this on the news but you
wouldn't hear that it was happening to
you
getting that phone call saying that
she's not here anymore just was like
the worst case
like a bad dream
and this is the man who murdered her on
the 25th of february this year kochi
sila maj a petrol station worker from
eastbourne and an albanian national
pleaded guilty
the 36 year old had driven to kidbrook
in southeast london from his home in
september last year to carry out a
premeditated attack on a woman with
extreme violence
he targeted the 28 year old as she made
her way through this park to meet a
friend
at this supermarket video shows him
purchasing a rolling pin before
returning to his car
it's there he swaps it for a motoring
warning triangle
selematch used it to strike sabine 34
times leaving her unconscious
he then dragged her into a long grassy
bank the prosecution maintains there was
a sexual motive
number plate recognition cameras helped
lead detectives to his address where a
search uncovered the shoes he'd been
wearing
blood found on the trainers matched the
victim
multiple pieces of evidence that brought
it all together and in my opinion put
selamar in a position where he had no
alternative other than plead guilty that
was the strength of the evidence
but it is what happened earlier that
raises questions at lunchtime on the day
of the attack he tried to check into a
room early he'd booked at the grand
hotel in eastbourne
but staff had become concerned and
called the police but they didn't attend
claiming the matter was resolved
salamaj would later return after he'd
committed the murder still wearing the
same clothes
after my sister's attack i was scared to
walk down the streets alone
i would come home during the day as long
as there's daylight
the thought of
coming home in the night was scary
making sure that i would walk down the
main road
rather than the side roads now
this case like that of sarah everard has
once again reignited the debates about
the safety of women in public places
but the sentence handed down is unlikely
to reassure them that things are going
to change